c'est un acte d'une grande cruauté et
d'une immense lâcheté dont on fait
preuve trois jeunes de la région de
belfort giflé et humilié lors d'une fête
d'anniversaire s'en prenant à une
personne en situation de handicap mental
durant toute une nuit
steven 22 ans était assoupi à la fin
d'une soirée trois personnes présentes à
cette fête s'en sont pris à lui le
filmant et l'humiliant sans relâche des
agresseurs qui sont allés jusqu'à lui
raser le crâne le violenter et diffusé
les images sur les réseaux sociaux à la
fin de son calvaire le jeune homme était
totalement perdu un jeune homme sans
histoire sur lequel des délinquants se
sont acharnés sans aucune empathie une
tragique histoire que vient dénoncer sa
soeur précis à ce soir sur notre plateau
[Musique]
alors les terribles images de
l'agression de steven vous avez vu c'est
c'est horrible après une semaine après
cette agression
donc sa soeur merci prescillia d'être là
et son beau-frère sont donc avec nous
pour nous raconter la colère l'émotion
et la douleur que traverse la famille
merci d'être là merci merci
stephen et si on peut vous dd on le fera
et j'ai vraiment envie de
enfin merci ce qu'ils veulent t'ils ce
jeudi salvatore et si on peut aider
steven et si je peux le rencontrer un
jour ça me fait extrêmement plaisir
voilà lui parler d'essayer de voilà de
le remonter le moral des décès de le
l'accompagner dans cette danse est cette
histoire compliquée alors au départ de
cette terrible affaire il y avait une
soirée samedi soir steven a prévenu de
avait prévu de rejoindre des amis pour
une petite soirée et c'est vite devenu
un guet-apens ct kwh alors cette
histoire
prescillia ou steven ne valait donc à
une soirée il devait 3 d'accord ils
étaient 3 d'accord ses deux potes à lui
qui connaissait c'était une copine que
l'accord il avait invité d'accord la
soirée se passe bien il a des souvent
des soirées comme ça non non non non non
on ne surveille étroitement d'accord moi
là bas comme vous savez les handicapés
sont souvent sujet aux moqueries voilà
ça c'est n'importe quand nous on fait
tout le maximum pour lui rendre la vie
il était content d'aller à cette soirée
si je suis invité à une soirée c'est un
bonheur et donc est là et là bas donc la
fin de soirée ne se passe pas
correctement tous tout tout chavire l'a
donc qu'est ce qui s'est passé en fait
ben apparemment donc sur snapshot
apparemment donc il y avait une
invitation qu'avait été fait et donc
d'autres personnes ont été invités à
cette soirée
beaucoup d'entre elles ont refusé cette
invitation et à partir donc on n'en sait
pas plus sain parce que l'enquêté en
cours alors à partir de 22h apparemment
ça a commencé à déraper et donc après la
suite vous l'avez quoi mais c'était un
ace et un guet-apens pour pour steven en
fait cette soirée la base on sait pas
voilà des vidéos on a sa part les vidéos
les réseaux sociaux on a vu où on avait
frappé steven qu'on lui avait attaché
les mains qu'on lui avait rasé les
cheveux qu'on
on rigolait
l'ubs est du déodorant dans les yeux les
yeux il voyait pu enfin c'était quoi
alors il paraît qu'au départ ce qu'ils
veulent ils
il a tenté de minimiser les faits il
disait que ça avait simplement été
quelques claques
voilà ce qui vous a dit puisque vous
l'avez récupéré c'est vous qui avait
récupéré steven valeur ces moments
pavois qui a récupéré steven dimanche en
fait il a été averti par une voisine qui
a vu les vidéos circuler sur les réseaux
donc à les convertir mon papa
directement et à partir de là donc il
est parti de chercher ils sont allés au
commissariat donc la planète n'ont pas
été reçus on lui a dit d'aller le
lendemain
au commissariat de gendarmerie puisque
c'était dans un village d'accord donc
moi le lendemain
je suis arrivé je n'ai pas pu travailler
ses mains et quand j'ai vu steven j'ai
dit je dis ça va il me fait oui ça va
parce qu'il ya c'est rien j'ai reçu que
quelques claques et moi j'ai vu ces
vidéos j'ai dit non steven tap a reçu
que quelques claques
c'est violent et il était comme dans un
déni est depuis mercredi donc mercredi
on allait au psychiatre et là il a
commencé à parler que des mots faut il a
dit qu'il va avec ses mots à lui il a
dit qu'il avait vécu quelque chose de
dramatique il avait vécu comme un
attentat voilà ils l'expriment comme ça
qu'ils pensaient pas s'en sortir qui
l'alimentent finir qu'il allait mal
finir qu'il allait pas nous voir donc
oui stephen harper maintenant arrivés
raconte l'histoire pourquoi il ya eu ce
ce basculement dans cette soirée qu'est
ce qui s'est passé en fait ben on sait
pas ici c'est pas lui même et il dit que
maintenant il a des flashs c'est parce
qu'ils à soirée se passait bien et puis
puis s'en sont pris à lui en fait un bon
amant il dormait
ils ont commencé à lui attacher les
miles on commence à le raser après ils y
ont tapé dessus c'était de la violence
gratuite quoi une autre victime est
également présent mais on n'en sait pas
plus parce qu'elle n'a pas voulu porter
plainte
il y avait une autre victime voilà qui à
l'heure actuelle n'a pas déposé plainte
les gendarmes l'ont interrogé donc alors
à donner d'autres éléments mais s'ils
veulent aujourd'hui c'est la question
que se posent les téléspectateurs fanni
va mal il a peur il à les perturber
il est perturbé là il va être suivi par
un psychiatre
trois fois par semaine à l'ime où il est
il est suivi oui vous avez porté plainte
bien sûr jouer mercredi à 5 personnes
qui ont été interpellées
oui grâce aux réseaux sociaux bain aux
personnes a réussi à savoir les
identités mais numéro de téléphone les
adresses de ces individus on a une
personne sur instagram dont qui a
dénoncé cette vidéo qui la fait partager
pour que tout le monde soit au courant
on le remercie témoigne avec nous à la
gendarmerie on ne le connaît pas la voix
lui il a eu le courage de venir bientôt
il est même venu devant tribunal hier
mais il n'a pas pu assister à l'audience
on a également le député qui nous a
beaucoup aidé au niveau des démarches
parce qu'au départ notre plainte n'était
pas recevable auprès du commissariat de
police pour eux c'est un bizutage
dimanche dans l'enceinte du rêve
maintenant donc le pape a tout de suite
dévasté et nous on a pris le relais
incroyable juste derrière gilbert dont
il faut saluer la réaction des gendarmes
qui eux ont pris la plainte et l'enquêté
d'aller très vite après puisque comme il
ya quatre personnes dont trois mineurs
qui sont jour est impliqué mais une
jeune femme de 22 ans il n'y a reconnu
sa culpabilité et qui a déjà été
condamné à six mois de prison avec
sursis
les injustices aussi dit oui oui je suis
d'accord avec vous c'est très faible
mais désarmés mais il hésite même s'ils
sont pas mis en examen à leur ont pas
les enquêteurs hésitent à placer les
mineurs en centre fermé pendant l'
enquête parce qu'ils ont peur que ces
mineurs face pressions et menaces encore
steven c'est incroyable qu'ils ont peur
de ça c'est fou ça dans quelques jours
donc à l'heure actuelle ils ont été
placés dans trois régions différentes
pour leur protection suite aux
nombreuses menaces et plainte dès lundi
pour le mieux pour le pur lynchage
mais bien sûr là c'est incroyable
incroyable pour m
une mine d'être venu nous voir ce soit
je voulais absolument que vous veniez
témoigner on aimerait bien rencontrer
stephen un jour je crois que vous avez
préparé un vous avez po paris ne sais
pas si c'était des notes que vous aviez
quelques notes lui en fait voilà on est
là pour steven aujourd'hui parce que
voilà c'est dramatique mais on voudrait
aussi dénoncé toute cette violence
gratuite auprès des personnes
vulnérables
on sait tous que tous les jours il ya
des violences gratuites auprès de ces
personnes des moqueries des violences
verbales et il faut vraiment que la
justice se rendent compte de la
situation ils sont en danger et les
voilà on était vraiment que ces actes
soient punis mais il faut que ça c'est
exactement je la gravité exacte
pardon mais il faut aller jusqu'au bout
moi j'ai vécu ça dans mon entourage
amical puisque j'ai fait partie d'un
rooney handicapés physiques et mentaux
pendant longtemps et récemment dans ma
propre famille on a dû traîner au
tribunal
quelqu'un qui justement c'est de la
maltraitance sur sur une personne en
situation de handicap
on est allé jusqu'au bout coup jusqu'au
mur là dessus et j'espère que j'espère
qu'il ya des gens du gouvernement hôte
qui nous regarde parce que là dessus il
faut vraiment durcir les sanctions
je suis complètement d'accord avec vous
priscilla et salvatore merci en tout cas
d'avoir été avec nous et je vous le dis
j'espère que vous viendrez me voir avec
steven si je peux lui remonter un peu le
moral reste un peu avec lui sam
ça me ferait plaisir merci beaucoup à
vous et à vous